[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était une fois ma mère leur rencontre
par hasard sur son lieu de travail
elle commence à parler avec lui et elle
est très vite touché par sa situation
mais aussi par sa force de caractère
c'est pourquoi elle lui propose de
l'héberger quelques semaines chez nous
son arrivée à la maison bouleverse nos
habitudes surtout pour lui avant de nous
connaître
il vivait seul et passait ses journées
avec ses amis en vivent avec nous il
doit s'habituer à vivre au milieu de
deux femmes
ce qui n'a jamais vécu auparavant les
premières semaines nous permettre
d'apprendre à nous connaître petit à
petit bien sûr les débuts sont un peu
timides mais finalement le fait de vivre
ensemble de se voir le matin au lever de
manger ensemble ça nous rapproche
automatiquement et très rapidement au
cours du temps
chacun trouve sa place dans cette
nouvelle organisation très vite les
semaines deviennent des mois sans qu'on
s'en rende vraiment compte est tout
simplement l'hébergement qui devait être
provisoire est devenu tout naturellement
permanent il commence également à
prendre des cours il est très déterminé
à apprendre de nouvelles choses et à
progresser
il est déjà très doué mais en plus de ça
il apprend très vite
ce qui fait qu'il est premier de sa
classe et qu'ils sont même des niveaux
bon après c'est sûr il al'avantage de
pouvoir réviser avec nous le soir à la
maison
en même temps il lui arrive de louper
quelques cours en fait il est hyperactif
quand il s'agit d'aider des amis ce qui
fait qu'il peut passer des journées
entières à courir à droite à gauche
juste pour aller les aider
et c'est aussi avec la même
détermination qu'il décide de créer une
association
le fait de vivre ensemble au quotidien
nous permet de voir nos habitudes et il
commence à prendre quelques unes de nos
habitudes notamment pour le shopping
il se prend au jeu de faire les magasins
faire des soldes et très vite il se
retrouve avec plus de paires de
chaussures que moi en fait
le voir changer ainsi ça nous permet à
ma mère et moi de nous voir comme dans
un miroir et de se rendre compte que
parfois notre manière de consommer et
peut-être un peu excessive
d'un autre côté nous aussi on s'inspire
de lui de son caractère calme et positif
on se rend compte qu'on a tendance à
stresser tout le temps à se plaindre de
tout et de rien alors que lui pas du
tout alors qu'il aurait aussi de quoi en
fait
il passe sa journée à chanter ils
chantent sous la douche en cuisinant et
même sur son vélo quand il rentre à la
maison
en le voyant on relativise et on se dit
que chanter tout le temps où vous
regarder des séries qui le font pleurer
et hurler de rire
en fait c'est sa manière à lui d'oublier
ce problème ne pas se focaliser dessus
un des moments forts de notre vie de
famille ça a été notre voyage à paris à
la base pour de la paperasse pour lui
mais on a décidé de passer quelques
jours là-bas de visiter la ville et on
s'est même fait plaisir dans un très bon
restaurant au cours du temps finalement
on a recréé une petite famille tous les
trois lui ma mère et moi
il sait moussa un jeune réfugié nigérian
de 23 ans aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il arrive en france et qu'ils
rencontrent ma mère il a tout juste 18
ans et il dort dans la rue les cours
qu'il prend ses des cours de français
qu'il prononce des associations et il
apprend très vite
est ce que les niveaux les révisions
avec nous
c'est au quotidien lorsqu'on discute
ensemble mais aussi lorsqu'il décide
d'essayer de déchiffrer le journal ou
lorsqu'il nous récite ses poésies qui la
prend en cours et qui sont très très
drôle
l'association qu'il a créée c'est une
association qui regroupe la communauté
nigériane de nancy notre voyage à paris
c'était pour ça demain l'entretien pour
sa demande d'asile et le très bon
restaurant
c'est un restaurant de spécialités
nigériane finalement les semaines qui
sont devenus des mois sont passés à des
années et nous avons vécu ensemble
pendant trois ans aujourd'hui et depuis
un an maintenant où ça a pris son envol
il a obtenu sa demande d'asile et il a
maintenant un travail et son propre
appartement
avec ma mère on a mis un peu de temps
avant de parler de notre situation à
notre entourage
[Musique]
au départ c'était surtout parce qu'on ne
savait pas vraiment où cette situation
allait nous mener mais aussi
probablement par peur de la réaction des
gens face à une situation atypique et
que certains pensaient parfois illégales
alors que ce n'était pas le cas
si je suis ici aujourd'hui c'est parce
que souvent je regrette de ne pas assez
parler de cette expérience autour de moi
parce que la rencontre avec nous avec
nous ça nous a beaucoup apporté à ma
mère et moi en plus de tous les moments
très drôles qu'on a passé ensemble
notamment quand moussa confondait sauce
bolognaise et sauce mayonnaise
on a beaucoup appris en le rencontrant
beaucoup appris sur notre manière de
vivre et notre manière de consommer
cette expérience nous a fait voir le
monde autrement nous a fait voir les
gens autrement et notamment les réfugiés
parce qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de monde
voit les migrants comme une masse qui
arrivent en france comme quelque chose
de dangereux
mais je pense aujourd'hui qu'il faut
apprendre à connaître les migrants parce
que ce sont des êtres humains des
personnes uniques avec leur propre
caractère
il faut donc apprendre à les connaître
individuellement à les questionner sur
leur envie leur passion leur rêve
découvrir leur caractère en fait c'est
comme rencontrer n'importe qui avec l'
avantage que toutes nos différences
qu'elles soient culturelles de vécu ça
ne peut que nous enrichir voir murray
voire même nous faire beaucoup rire
enfin
si je suis ici c'est également pour
remercier moussa le remercier pour tout
ce qui nous a apporté
je voudrais lui dire merci pour ce
partage culturel unique pour sa joie de
vivre et son calme très communicatif lui
dire merci pour tous les moments de fou
rire qu'on a passé ensemble pour sa
force de caractère qui est un exemple
aujourd'hui pour moi et enfin pour être
devenu un grand frère dont je suis si
fier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]